foreign
what's up Charlotte what's up Taylor in
Charlotte
Hi how are you good I'm talking to
Charlotte in Taylor North Carolina
what's up what's up Taylor
communication problems that I'm having
with my husband I'm sorry I'm really
really nervous oh that's okay you should
be because I don't know any married
people that have communication problems
I
kind of scary but um so what's up the
main gist of it is sorry um
is that I feel constantly
ignored about my feelings and my
requests
um especially in matters of like you
know safety whoa and everything we're a
daughter yeah tell me about that
um
so basically there are there are a
couple of like you know big events that
I know like after binge listening to
your show that I know that there's like
a logical thing that my brain is trying
to do and that my body
is not feeling safe in certain things
but um just like basic things that he
just I can't seem to communicate with
him that are like real safety things
like for instance I know it sounds small
but for me it feels like such a big
thing um like shutting the gate at the
top of the stairs
you know things like that where I'm like
please shut the gate at the top of the
stairs like this is very important our
daughter is extraordinarily hyperactive
she be lines up for the stairs I really
need you to shut the gate to the point
where he doesn't listen he doesn't
actually follow through and I I've had
to put signs up like please do this like
as a reminder and it still doesn't
happen where else where else does he not
show up
um
he just
his communication he knows he's bad at
communication he recognizes that and
I'll I'm very blunt and I'll point it
out but like you're not communicating
with me well and then we'll have like a
good stretch of like a a couple weeks
where he tries and then he just
completely waves off so just the way
that he speaks to me he speaks to other
people where he doesn't realize that he
comes off as cold Taylor you how long
have you been with him
uh eight years we've been married for
five okay you have been covering for him
and protecting him a long time
and you curated the staircase thing
which by the way is a big deal
if you've ever been to a house where a
toddler's gone tumbling down the stairs
it is not funny it is a big deal
but you picked that story
and lieu of other ones because you've
defended this guy for a long time
give me an example of where he's not
safe
and be honest oh God
I'm right right I want
to no no no no no no no no
defending him on this call he's a grown
man
um
those things out to him that are unsafer
that he's getting too angry or trying to
argue with me in front of our daughter I
try to remove her from the situation
and there was a situation and it was it
feels so stupid because it was months
ago but um I was upstairs getting ready
to go to work and I heard my daughter
crying and it wasn't like a normal cry
like a mom knows when a cry isn't normal
and I know that she can be very
difficult during you know like dinner
time and things like that this is like
right before she turned two and I came
down the stairs and he didn't see that I
was right there and he was so angry at
her for not wanting to eat her food that
he grabbed her leg and shook it and like
cried out in anger and the first thing I
did I ran over I wasn't yelling or
shouting because I was just trying to
get my hysterical scared daughter out of
there and I picked her up and I swooped
her up and I was like we are we are
leaving we are going upstairs I'm
separating this is this is not happening
and I grabbed her and she just cleaning
to me and I took her upstairs
and he followed us upstairs he's like no
don't take her away I'm so so sorry I'm
so sorry I was like no we need space we
need space she needs space and he
followed me up the stairs and healing
would not leave us alone like he
wouldn't stop and I tried to go into our
bedroom
and he was trying to get into the room
and I had her on my hip and I'll try and
close the door and lock it so that way
we could just get the space for her to
calm down
and he repeatedly hit me with the door
while I was holding her and I was like
you're hurting me you're gonna hurt her
and he was like then you need to let me
in you have to let me in let me
apologize to her I'm sorry you have to
let me apologize to her and I was like
please like you're scaring us like
you're scaring her she's crying and he
repeatedly slammed the door and then I
finally got enough leverage against the
bed to shut it and lock it and he just
like wept out in the hallway
and then after like an hour I finally
felt okay for him to see her again and
he like wept over her he felt awful he's
never done anything like this before
he's never hit me he's never hit her
or anything he's all awful
and he was like I'm so sorry that will
never happen again but
I feel like I let it I let it go too
easy and now everything's like bubbling
up where I'm just like seeing things
like a gate being left open and I just I
lose my mind hold on you should Taylor
because you're not safe
and I'm you've listened to the show you
said for a while you know I am
as forgiving as they come when people do
something stupid it happens to all of us
right and we live in a world now where a
teacher can be perfect just do great
work for 20 years and then she pops off
and says one thing and then she's fired
like that's the world we're in I don't
want to participate in that world
but when someone is violent with a child
followed up by violence with his wife
and here's the concern
there's a rage that is scary
but there is a self-centeredness
I will hurt you so that I can make
myself feel better by saying sorry
and here's the big deal to me
somebody snaps they get scream at their
kid they whatever
I used to tell my students all the time
doing something stupid in a moment does
not mean you have bad character where
I'm going to look for character is what
happens immediately afterwards
and there's been no change no I need to
go see somebody no will you forgive me
no contriteness no hey how do I love you
better today how do I love you better
today
there's been a hey man it's cool it was
it was a wild night wasn't it
and now we're back to old Taylor
I mean we're back to old household
and if you go back and listen to this
call you've apologized for your daughter
being loud she's two years old for God's
sakes
you've apologized for you you've
apologized for
you have all of the the
um vocal mannerisms of someone who's in
a very abusive unsafe situation
I believe you I believe you when you say
he's never done this before or after I
believe you
but your body is running on Razor's Edge
right
yeah
I don't know where it came from I just I
he's such a
a good guy and he's he tries like he
goes through these big stages of like a
really really trying Taylor Taylor
Taylor Taylor really really trying is
not enough here
it's not enough
you change
if you're trying to fix your car and all
you have in your tool kit is a hammer
and you smash the engine to pieces
you immediately
resolve to a go get new tools because
you don't have the right tools to fix
this thing
and B get somebody to teach you how to
do it
and infinitely more important than a
stupid car engine is a daughter and a
wife
yeah
and I'm telling you right now Taylor I
I'm
I'm gonna honor your silence here
I'm gonna honor your silence
and what I say about that is I've been
prying a little bit and you don't want
to talk and that about some of them
that's fine
I know you're not safe
and whatever that looks like
he's never I
was like raised his voice at our
daughter like I know really you know
what he did he unplugged
instead of solving the problem he
detached from it
so instead of being a rageful angry guy
now he's numb
and he won't even lock the gate he won't
even do small basic things to keep your
daughter safe to make you feel loved to
make you feel safe inside your own home
because he's so untrustful of himself
that he can't plug back in and listen I
applaud him for unplugging for a second
but at some point he's gotta be a dad
and be a husband
right and
it was it was just so crazy because like
he had never even if he's never ever
raised a hand at me he's never been
violently like shouted at me or anything
like that before and I asked him I was
like is there like something going on
okay let's do this let's do this
he did what he did right
yeah and
you and I both know
that maybe not in that it's that type of
wild evening
there have been other things that make
you feel unsafe
here's what's important you can't
control his actions or his thoughts you
can't
there's not some magic thing you haven't
said
there's not some like oh man if I had
just done this then maybe he would
he's making choices he's an adult
at the end of the day you are going to
have to decide
what your boundaries and what safety
looks like for you
you're gonna have to communicate them in
a very direct and clear way
here's what I mean
I mean you take him out to lunch or take
him out to breakfast and you start the
conversation with this is going to be a
very hard conversation
and if you lose your temper or you get
angry
I am going to leave
if you tell me that what my feelings are
are my feelings are stupid I'm Gonna
Leave
I need you to listen directly to me
without responding can you do that and
if he's a grown-up he'll say yes then
you tell him I have not been able to
come back from what happened a few
months ago a few weeks ago
I still haven't taken a full breath
I still can't but uh I haven't done
anything I know I know this is me
I can't breathe
so the only path forward I see for us
right now is that you and I go see a
marriage counselor ASAP
and I've already got us an appointment
if you don't go
I hear you telling me you are not
interested in being married to me
if you do go I hear you saying you're
very sorry about what happened and
you're willing to learn new tools so
that we can create a great family
together
do you hear what I'm saying Taylor
that's how Direct
yeah
but if you go in and you're like well
I'm so sorry that she didn't want to eat
that night no she's two of course
two-year-olds don't eat every night
they're just bundles of nerves
I feel like
honestly like you're right right I've he
always says like you know we even talked
about I asked him like after the
incident happened I I came downstairs
and I was surprisingly very calm after I
put my daughter to bed and I was I I
threatened him and I was like if this
ever happens again I will I will leave
you I will take my daughter
and we will leave
I'll say it doesn't matter how much I'm
in love with you but we will go and I
feel like that that scared him into not
doing anything like I said he he adores
he adores her he really does that's why
I feel like it just came out of the blue
and I don't know what happened but it
isn't the first time that I feel like
his feelings
you know of what he's feeling in that
moment of my safety is is disregarded
and you know like in the questions that
I that I wrote you guys it obviously
your body is telling you something and
it leaks into the attraction of your
marriage
because your body you like can look at
your husband and be like wow he is you
know excuse me like he is so hot but
like my body is like no I don't I don't
feel as comfortable as I should yeah
here's the thing I think you know as
well as I do
this marriage has way more problems than
you have ever wanted to say publicly out
loud
I think it's going to be really
important for you to take a yellow path
and start writing stories down
one after the other
and I know there are good stories too
you'll talk about that with your
counselor but I want you to take stories
I want you to write them down one after
another after another after another
because I think if you look at them out
of your body on a piece of paper you're
going to find one of two things there's
been two or three big blow-ups over the
course of your marriage
that need to be addressed they have to
be addressed
or you're going to find 30 or 40. you're
going to realize oh my gosh my body's
been trying to get my attention for
eight years
because we're not safe I'm not safe now
I brought a baby girl into this and
she's not safe
you're gonna have to write down what you
need you have to write down what you
want you have to write down what your
boundaries are and you have to
communicate them directly and remember
this behavior is a language if he loves
you and he loves that little girl and
he's all in on creating something
extraordinary a life together it'll be
all in
if he walks away
he's telling you everything you need to
hear
thank you so much for the call Taylor
I'm so so sorry